okay today we have a second installment
of Trumpets whose mind you can't change
for today's voicemail segment the
voicemail number of course is two one
nine two david p yesterday we had one
example of a woman woman or i don't know
what age he was a woman who made it
clear that it's not a good strategy to
go and try to convince Trumpets to
change their mind that's not how we're
going to win twenty twenty I have
another example of that for you today
take a listen to what the truth comes
out and all your liberal lives and stuff
or like made known what are you guys
gonna do right do you guys gonna root
for when all the bad guys are locked up
when the when the Obamas and Clintons
and bushes all the deep Staters are
locked up what are you guys gonna do
then he's gonna pay your bills there's
going on I'm saying you guys better get
on the right side the right side the
reality guys I'm telling you you're on
the wrong side of reality yeah so listen
as far as paying bills I've said before
you know Trump in office has been good
for the show in terms of the business of
the show it's been terrible for the
country and I still prioritize the
country over the show I can assure you
that if circumstances in the United
States lead to Barack Obama Hillary
Clinton and George W Bush being in
prison I think the show will be doing
just fine but of course you know deep
state conspiracies all of this stuff we
can't talk these folks out of the
worldview that they've adopted not in
any sensible amount of time so the focus
must be the focus has to be get the vote
out from people that are on our side
already make sure they don't stay home
and let's try to improve the country
that way because arguing with folks like
that and the person that called in
yesterday it's an exercise in futility
it's it's it's simply not worth it it's
not worth our time we can get way more
people to vote before we can get one of
these folks to change their mind on
today's bonus show George papadopolis is
running for Congress and he announced it
we're of course on Fox and Friends we
will talk about that t-mobile has a
trademark on the color magenta and is
demanding that an insurance company stop
using that particular hue we will dis
cus that and the limits of intellectual
property also may be good news
Donald Trump has signed an animal
cruelty bill into law interesting when
in the video I showed you earlier of
Trump with a dog he seemed to have
absolutely no affection or empathy for
the dog whatsoever in fact seemed to
want nothing to do with the dog despite
calling the dog brilliant and extremely
smart we will talk about the animal
cruelty bill on today's bonus show how
do you get access to the bonus show it's
very easy sign up for a membership at
join pakman.com become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can also get on our mailing list at
david pakman.com and this friday Black
Friday everybody on our mailing list
will get an email with a one-time use
coupon code for an obscene discount off
of a david pakman show membership so if
you want to sign up but you want the
best membership discount of the year
just get on our newsletter at david
pakman.com and friday I would guess
early afternoon you will find in your
email inbox a very special one day only
one-time use code for a discount at
david pakman show membership in the
meantime we will talk to you on the
bonus show today tomorrow the chess
showdown between producer Pat and me
will take place we have all been
preparing I've been doing I've been
working on my lats actually to prepare
for the chess match more on that
tomorrow though